actually the 99th year were in of the of
this endowment for this lectureship and
the Dwight Terry lectureship was
established obviously then in nineteen
five by a gift from Dwight Harrington
Terry of Bridgeport Connecticut to endow
a series of lectures on religion and its
application to human welfare in the
light of scientific knowledge and
philosophical insights and thus bridging
much of what we do here at Yale
University the lectures are published in
book form by Yale University Press and
over the years we've had a distinguished
series of lecturers and we're I to sit
here and listen to these lecturers I
would feel somewhat daunted we've had
Margaret Mead Paul Tillich John Dewey
Carl Jung Stephen Jay Gould Reinhard
kneeboard Gigi Simpson Erich Fromm and
Rebecca West among others a very
distinguished lecturers today's lecture
and lecturer is David Sloan Wilson who
holds the position as professor of
Biological Sciences and a joint
appointment in the anthropology
department at Binghamton University in
New York State
David is also the director of Ivo's a
program founded in 2003 that seeks to
make evolutionary theory part of the
common discourse for all subjects
relevant to human affairs in the natural
world he received his bachelor's degree
from the University of Rochester in 1971
and his PhD from Michigan State
University in 1975 he's author of a
number of books among them the natural
selection of populations and communities
he's a specialist in group selection
theory and the resuscitation of group
selected the selection theory in biology
a book called unto others the evolution
and psychology of unselfish behavior
and probably his most famous book which
is the book Darwin's Cathedral evolution
religion and the nature of society
published in 2002 I recently inquired at
the Yale bookstore and they did not have
any copies in stock but they as a result
of these lectures are rushing to do so
and within a couple of days there should
be a shipment of dr. Wilson's book at
the at the bookstore he David Wilson is
currently working on a another book
called the literary animal the evolution
and the nature of narrative with
Jonathan Gottshall and this will be an
effort to to look at literature in the
same vein that he's been looking at
other areas of human endeavor in human
society in an evolutionary perspective
finally I just want to say that he is a
passed Guggenheim Fellow the vice
president of the American Society of
naturalists in 1977 and the recipient of
SUNY's Chancellor's award for excellence
in scholarship and creative activities
I'm going to lay out very quickly the
program for lectures over the next two
weeks these lectures are held on
Tuesdays and Thursdays of two
consecutive weeks I want to first of all
say that following today's lecture and
the subsequent lectures there will be a
reception unfortunately not in this Hall
not in Luce Hall but across Prospect
Street which is over that way at 124
Prospect so you should go out the set of
doors on the north side of the building
turn left walk across Prospect Street
walk across the parking lot and you
should see the door for 124 Prospect
Street and another word from our sponsor
following the lecture there will be a
suit there will be a question period if
there's anyone who wishes to carry on
further discussions with dr. Wilson or
has further questions please go to the
Terry website wwlp.com
edu / tere lecture and followed the
instructions to get on to the
interactive website with dr. Wilson this
is a way to extend and expand the dialog
as I said this will be a series of four
lectures today dr. Wilson will be
talking about his topic rather will be a
sociological break through how to make
evolution part of the common language of
academic and everyday life
Thursday at 4:30 all of the lectures
here in loose all Thursday at 4:30
groups as organisms and organisms as
groups and then next week on Tuesday
January the 25th the human social
organism and finally on Thursday the
27th applied evolutionary theory I think
I've spoken long enough and I by the way
I'm Leo Hickey who's in the geology and
geophysics Department you can see how
broadly the net of the Terry lectures is
cast in this regard and without any
further ado I will introduce our speaker
David Sloan Wilson it's a real pleasure
thank you very much
well thank you so much it's course it's
a great honor to be asked to give these
lectures and humbling to stand in the
shadow of such distinguished
predecessors the broad theme of my talks
is stated here how evolutionary theory
provides a common language for the study
about subjects relevant to human affairs
in the natural world and this might be
broken into two parts the first is the
goal of and the general goal of
integration how can we possibly escape
the specialization of knowledge which
has been taking place for so long
resulted in the major disciplines as we
know them such as anthropology
psychology and so on and ever finer
subdivisions as as the volume of
knowledge explodes is there any way to
achieve some kind of more holistic view
of in general secondly the possibility
of evolutionary theory in particular as
a way to achieve integration now the
goal of integration of course is very
close to the mission of the Cherry
lectureship as we just as we just heard
and interestingly enough so also is
evolutionary theory because even though
evolution is not mentioned by name it
turns out that a surprising number of
previous cheriya lecturers have
addressed the subject of evolution from
Jay a Thompson in 1924 all the way up to
Francisco Ayala just a few years ago
evolution more than any other subject is
the subject that the cherry lectureship
has returned to again as again as
somehow fundamental to the integration
of science with these traditions of of
religion and and philosophy nevertheless
and of course this is think the Tori
luxury ship stands as a microcosm for
intellectual history general and ever
since Darwin it's been clear that there
were momentous consequences for our
understanding of all things he
and of course we've been trying to
achieve that understanding all along but
it's stubbornly refuses to be realized
the innovative potential of a narrow
theory stubbornly refused to be realized
I was very interested to read George
Gaylord Simpsons book from the cherry
lecture is one of the books that became
a true classic he's in the present study
the factual truth of organic evolution
is taken is established and the inquiry
goes on there that was in 1949 and here
we are 56 years later and guess what
creationism is still alive and and well
stronger than ever perhaps and it's easy
to be smug about creationists but gets
worse if you look at those who accept
the fact of evolution the great majority
usually don't relate it to matters of
importance in their own lives for them
evolution is about dinosaurs and fossils
and and people evolving from from apes
but if you ask them if evolution has
anything to do with the paper that you
open or or current affairs or how you
regard your life or your work and in
most cases the answer would be no and it
gets worse
very interesting lack of integration
within academia even within the
biological sciences you might think that
aldub Jansky said in the 1970s had a
famous quote that nothing makes sense in
biology except in the light of evolution
but the fact is is that there's plenty
of integration that's still in progress
within the biological sciences our best
model of integration is in the fields of
ecology evolution and behavior I just
had lunch with Glenn trigger and he said
no ecology is not very well integrated
but the innovation that took place
didn't really come together until I
would say the 1960s of the 1970s a
development and evolution there's a
catchy phrase evo-devo
representing the integration of
evolution and development and that
phrase I believe came about in the 1990s
molecular biology and the Health
Sciences are in norm
a sophisticated incredably sophisticated
in their study of approximate mechanisms
but they're not well integrated for the
most part with other aspects of
evolutionary biology so the field for
example the term Darwinian medicine as
an other phrase that was coined in the
1990s and it's still not in the
curricula most medical medical schools
as we moved from the biological sciences
to the so-called human sciences it gets
worse all of these subjects traditional
divisions of the human sciences of
course from the very beginning of an
effort to integrate evolution with these
topics but for the most part they failed
and so the terms evolutionary psychology
and evolutionary anthropology and their
modern usage date about to the 1990s
they have an era of heresy about them
and so much of this integration is still
in the future it's very easy to get your
PhD in these disciplines without ever
having a course in evolution or or using
the e word as we move from the Human
Sciences to the so-called humanities an
interesting distinction that we need to
think about in our quest for integration
that gets worse so much so that really
many people wouldn't know what you would
mean to say that you might approach in
literature or music or dance from a from
an evolutionary perspective or might
even invoke great hostility as it does
for example in cultural studies a great
taboo about about about Darwinism I
spend a lot of time on these subjects
and so I know from experience
léo mentioned of an edited book that's
just coming out on literature from an
evolutionary perspective and publishing
that book was an amazing ordeal so I
have first-hand experience for just how
controversial it is to approach these
studies from a evolutionary perspective
I'll be talking about religion in detail
mostly during my during my third
lectures so what we see 50 years after
Simpson 80 years after Thompson is still
a failures of integration especially for
human related topics and this is a real
puzzle you know it's perfectly possible
or we could go 50 more years and someone
else will be standing here
maurella saying the same thing and so we
really want to know what are the
limiting factors that are preventing
progress from being more rapid there's
there's the usual list of subjects for
example we might say that the all these
topics are so difficult there's not
enough information there might be
challenges studying these subjects
scientifically especially humans and I
think that these are might be true to a
degree but they're really missing the
point and we're not identifying the true
limiting factors which instead are
elsewhere and more interesting so what I
want to establish today is that the
limiting factors I think are primarily
psychological and sociological and most
importantly they can be circumvented I
want to show that numerous individuals
are already functioning is what I call
extreme integrationists in the sense
that Darwin was I will as I will shortly
describe I want to establish that
students can be taught to function as
extreme integrationists in a single
semester also that integration can be
implemented at a university-wide scale
so it's possible for for integrated
evolutionary studies to take place at
the scale of an entire university as
we're trying to do with Evo's and so and
with Evo's and other programs if there's
already working models from which to
borrow so what this means is is that I
think that the future pace of
integration can be much faster than the
past if this lecture differs from
previous cherry lectureships on biology
it's in its practical nature what I
think I can do is to establish something
close to a how-to manual for achieving
integration based on elements which
already exist and I will sketch that out
for you in this lecture I'll try to
flesh it out in my subsequent lectures
and in the book that will be published
I will try to accomplish this in in book
form
so to substantiate these claims let me
go back to good ol Charles Darwin
everyone loves to go back to Charles
Darwin and I think it's very important
to remember that he functioned as an
extreme integrationist from the very
beginning he himself regarded his theory
he called it one long argument
everything fit into one long argument
and what do I mean by extreme
integration all taxa were open to his
study he could study barnacles on Monday
orchids on Tuesday earthworms on
Wednesday words on Thursday so whatever
he had allowed him to transcend
taxonomic groups also all subjects he
could say pollination on Monday
biogeography on Tuesday weaponry on
Wednesday somehow was he he was able to
incorporate all subjects and include
humans along with the rest of life so at
the same time that he was soaking seeds
to see how long they'd survive in
seawater he was sending questionnaires
to military officers in the far-flung
outposts of the the British Empire
asking them to look at the emotional
expressions of the native inhabitants
there because he he thought that there
was an innate inist to to emotional
expression and he was doing actual
research on human aspects of humanity
and thinking hard about Moral Sentiments
and quoting philosophers of his of his
time at the same time as he was studying
sex in in in and barnacles and this is
so amazing because this is the dream of
integration that we hold in the future
this is what we want to achieve
basically and it's what Darwin was doing
already doing so how can we explain this
kind of transdisciplinarity and there's
the usual explanations of course maybe
Darwin was just one hell of a great guy
and he was make no mistake but I think
it's also a mistake to deter patiska
integration purely to his
personal attributes I think that would
be unfortunate of course because that's
something we can really emulate and
other possibility is that there was less
knowledge back then and so with less to
learn it was possible to be more of a
generalist and this might also be true
to a degree but the really interesting
possibility because it's the possibility
that we can copy and emulate is that
there's something about the theory which
enabled him to be so integrative and
that this was possible even in its most
rudimentary form because after all
Darwin didn't even know about genes
there was all kinds of stuff that he
didn't know about so whatever he knew
about evolutionary theory was just the
kernel of evolutionary theory and yet
this was enough for him to function in a
way that we dream about in the future
isn't this interesting I think that this
is a fascinating juxtaposition of
possibilities now if we fast forward to
the present what we discover is is that
it is common not at all unusual for
modern evolutionary biologists to
transcend taxa and subjects in the style
of Darwin now clearly there's some
people that choose a particular system
and they stick with it their whole life
there's great advantages to that all
kinds of social knowledge techniques
that you can build up but it's very
common for someone and I'm an example to
pick my concepts pick my organism so in
my career I started out studying zou
plankton I proceeded to insects I've
started fish birds plants microbes
that's taxa transcending and subject
I've considered a foraging predator
defense cooperation ovarian development
pick your topic pick your organism and
there's an advantage of doing that
because often a particular organism is
the best one to study a particular topic
so that if you want to study a new topic
it's often good to move to a new
organism and believe me I'm not
comparing myself to Darwin in terms of
in terms of personal attributes that
would be boring I'm saying that the
theory which serve Darwin allowed him to
be integrative also allow
the modern evolutionary biologists to be
innovative and this says something very
interesting about this problem of
information load back in Darwin's day
there was perhaps too little information
although of course there was a lot today
we have much too much information we're
buried by information and yet it's
possible to function in this integrative
mode fill out this full range Darwin can
do it and the modern evolutionary
biologist can do it so somehow this this
way of thinking that allows us to be so
integrative is something which can exist
independently amount of the amount of
information available and the reason is
simple enough it's because what the
theory provides is a way of organizing
existing information and seeking new
information regardless of how much
information is currently available and
that's why it's independent of the
amount of information for those
evolutionary biologists who choose to
study humans they continue to function
as extreme integrationist the fact that
they moved to humans as opposed to
nonhumans really makes no difference in
their style of thinking so and at the
same time that I've been studying the
animals and the topics in the previous
slide I've been studying decision making
the nature of physical attractiveness a
great topic the philosophical concept of
the naturalistic fallacy of food sharing
in hunter-gatherer societies general
concept of social transmission so
important for culture altruism the
nature of stories individual differences
in personality religion human rights
impulsiveness and the list of course
could go on and on so think humans or
other animals this way of thinking
allows the professional scientists to
transcend disciplines to this to this
degree so this is a thumbnail sketch at
the level of professional activities
what we is also possible to teach
extreme innovation in the classroom for
many years I've taught a class on
evolution and human behavior usually at
the upper love
recently I switched so that it's a
freshman class for non-majors and and
the last time I taught this you can
believe I had lots of majors from
anthropology art and biology to
philosophy physics psychology and
women's studies all different kinds of
backgrounds and in the first half of the
class I teach the basic principles of
evolutionary theory and in the second
half of the class we use the basic
principles and we function as extreme
integrationist we've studied topic after
topic then they choose their own topic
and they have the greatest time talking
about everything from from attention
deficit disorder to yawning so this can
be done at the at the undergraduate
level the students love this class
here's some anonymous comments so the
students have nothing to gain from
making these these comments and listen
to these comments so this is what
students get after a single semester
exposure this course provides evidence
that evolution is evident everything it
LEvolution dies my way of viewing
problems this course changed the way I
look at things in general I try to see
and understand them from an evolutionary
perspective now this course shows how
positive evolution can be it teaches you
a great deal and increases one's
interest and I want you to focus on
positive here the fact that this person
and really the class in general comes to
see evolution as something which is a
positive thing not threatening but
positive I came into this class not
knowing a lot about evolution I now have
an entirely now new outlook on how
evolution can be applied to many aspects
of life so here's someone who came into
the class not knowing much about
evolution and here's someone who came
into the class who knows who had a lot
of background I take an evolution
classes from high school and never felt
it was interesting but this class
changed all my views upside down the
most boring theories became interesting
thoughts that I could relate to my own
day-to-day life and here is this on the
actual forum she marked a 10-4
class has changed your view with a
little happy face and she voted it's not
boring anymore and I think that this
really tells us something so very
interesting when you compare this which
I can do reliably class after class
there's nothing there's nothing unusual
about this nor is it unusual in the
sense that I'm the only one that can do
with this others of my colleagues can do
this can take a population of students
without any expertise and do this time
after time how can we reconcile this
with the famous inability to teach
people about evolution that comes
through and survey after after survey
what is going on that we have such night
and day kind of differences in response
to evolution now with the help of two
experts in science pedagogy Brian alters
and Craig Nelson I was careful to a
quantitatively assess this class because
it's so interesting to answer this
question basically and and of course
pedagogy can be studied scientifically
along with anything else and so we did
before and after surveys we assessed
prior knowledge of evolution importance
of religion in their lives
everything from atheist to devoutly
religious a political orientation from
left to right and also general thinking
style without reference to subject
matter and in all of these cases even
though the students who took my course
no doubt were a biased sample of the
university population and the university
population was a biased sample of the
general population the fact was was that
the students varied Morales over the
full range of responses for all of these
measures so I had everyone from atheist
to to be religiously devout from
political conservatives to liberals lots
of evolutionary background very little
and so on that took the that took the
class and the results of the assessment
are interesting the course of course was
highly successful at changing views you
could see that from the student comments
and that was also reflected
quantitatively but what was so
interesting was that the course
succeeded across the spectrum of
religious and
little believes in other words there was
no correlation with what the religious
values or political values of the
student and how much they liked the
course neither did the course alter
their political or religious value if
they were devout coming in they were
devout going out they didn't it did not
challenge their faith in in God and
their faith in God did not prevent them
from appreciating the virtues of of this
theory and even though evolutionary
theory historically has been associated
with great wing ideological doctrines
there was no relationship that left
feminists and and and and the people who
dress in black were just as happy with
evolutions as as the as the right wings
so it did improve general reasoning
skills when you measure what the kinds
of thinking that we associate with
scientific reasoning which means that
you don't regard everything as just
facts at the same time you don't think
that everyone's just entitled to their
opinion that you actually need to
evaluate stuff so if can be right or
wrong and that there's a procedure for
telling which is which this kind of
thinking actually was increased apart
from any particular subject matter as a
result of the class so these are
obviously results to die for as far as
as far as a teaching is concerned and so
you know how does this course work so
well I can show that if succeeds and now
let's try to think why does it succeed
so well and there's a number of
pedagogical devices which can be taught
for any subject matter if I had more
time I'd be I'm very interested in this
in this subject but I've left it out for
lack of time the little essence as to
why this course works so well I think
can be explained by these three words
unthreatening explanatory and useful I
managed to present evolution in a way
which is in the first place
unthreatening it does not necessarily
lead to dire consequences
in the second place its explanatory it
explains the world as it existed in the
past and exists in the present and in
the third it's useful you can use the
theory to make the world better if
that's whatever that means according to
your dictate and any theory that is an
unfriending explanatory and useful is
going to be psychologically alluring I'm
always amazed when we when I look at
discussions about teaching evolution how
much they work at the driving in the
facts of evolution oh it's just you know
certain certain certain almost no
attention to the consequences and one
thing that you can say actually as an
evolutionary biologist about all forms
of mentality including human mentality
is that it's consequence driven all
forms of mentality are designed to
produce adaptive outcomes and so if
you're asked to accept a belief which in
your mind is going to lead to bad
outcomes even really bad outcomes a
threatening ideas like any other kind of
threat the impulse is to kill it or run
away from it and if you take the same
idea and if you make it alluring then
the then the impulse is to embrace it
neither one of those are scientifically
respectable we're supposed to accept
ideas when they're when they're true
regardless of the of the consequences
but certainly you want to work on the
implications of what you're teaching
someone or if you could make it
unthreatening explanatory and useful
then people will want to learn it and
the only limiting factor then becomes
the intrinsic difficulty of the subject
and as it turns out evolutionary theory
is not intrinsically difficult it's not
like the theory of relativity which is
intrinsically difficult you can teach
the basic principle of natural selection
in five minutes and the big question is
not what is it or does it happen it's
why should anyone make a big deal out of
it so it's so interesting to approach
this at this at this level now so what
is it that they actually learn what are
the basic principles
minimum basic principles that a person
needs to get going to function as an
extreme integrationist I'm going to list
these and of course in the course it
takes me about half the semester to go
through them properly I hope to go
through them properly in the book that I
write for this series here of course I
have to go through them improperly I'm
going to dash through them in this
lecture and then during the subsequent
lectures I will have a chance to return
to these but here is just a flyby
basically and by far and away the most
important concept to get across is the
concept of adaptation ISM that is the
centerpiece of Darwin's theory and I
call it a third way of thinking in a way
that I'm going to elaborate it is so
simple yet profound once I get the
concept of adaptation across it's
important to elaborate upon it because
the biological concept of adaptation is
very different than the concept of the
general concept of usefulness the
everyday concept of adaptation and it
turns out that many things that count is
adaptive in the biological sense of the
word are not at all adaptive they're
destructive as the in the everyday sense
of the word biological adaptations are
often short-sighted and selfish and they
lead to dysfunctional outcomes at larger
temporal and spacial scales and so it's
like the folktale where the person is
given a wish and then the wish turns out
very differently than they then they
expect him when you could talk about
adaptations it's just not lead to benign
outcomes by any means at all and so you
have to be careful what you wish for
with adaptations and then the third
point is is that when we feature
adaptation ISM the importance of
adaptation ISM we're not saying that
everything is adaptive and this is the
point that Stephen Jay Gould made again
and again and again throughout
throughout his career there's more
evolution and adaptation adaptation is
something which evolves only by a very
sort of messy process and there's all
kinds of stuff that happens basically
that prevents organisms from being well
adapted to their environment and these
three things taken together means that
the very best that evolutionary theory
is a kind of a framework for asking
questions in which there's more than one
plausible alternative it never just
gives you the right answer straight away
and of course I don't think any theory
does so unless you can actually take
these hypotheses and test them and then
go back and revise the hypothesis as you
go through a cycle which we know is the
scientific process then you're dead in
the water and so you really have to do
science and and this might seem to be
elementary but as we'll see and
evolution circles about about this and
then finally the final point is that
there's more to evolution than genetic
evolution so evolution is Darwin knew it
if there's three ingredients phenotypic
variation heritability and fitness
consequences the mechanisms of
heritability might be genetic or they
might not and so when you think of
evolution in terms of the most basic
ingredients it admits certain
psychological processes developmental
processes and cultural processes which
count as fast-paced evolutionary
processes and so it creates an
open-ended element especially to humans
human individuals as adaptive systems as
evolving systems human cultures as
evolving systems which solve some of the
problems that arise when we limit
evolutionary thinking just to genetic
pollution so in a very fast way that is
the the basic principles of evolution
that I am to the students now let me
just try to go over there so I'm going
to keep within my time limits here so I
might just skip over some things but let
me just go over this and a little bit
more detail beginning with adaptation
ISM and to make you believe ask you to
believe that you're a student in my
class that so it is of course many of
you almost all of you are highly
distinguished in your own rights but I
think that it would be an interesting
exercise just to imagine that you're an
undergraduate student in my class and to
see how I present these ideas to
somebody who's often just encountering
them for the first hand so suppose that
I place an object
in your hand and it could be a mineral
it could be nonliving or or living and I
asked you to explain to me its
properties and before Darwin you'd have
only two ways of explaining the
properties of the of the object either
you could use a theological explanation
that this is God's handiwork or a
material explanation I took it apart and
it's made out of certain minerals and so
on and so forth
these would be the only two ways that
you would have to explain to me the
properties of this of this object and
what Darwin's theory did was provide a
third way of explaining the properties
of living objects in the case of a bird
for example you could say the bird has
the property it does because it
basically it enables it to survive and
reproduce and it's in its environment
there was a process of selection that
was variation heritability selection and
now this animal is well designed to
survive and reproduce in its environment
now everyone knows that this a kind of
explanation is different than a
theological explanation but it's a
little more subtle to say that this kind
of explanation is different than a
materialistic explanation the best way
to get this across is by using the
metaphor of a sculpture if I were to
hand you a sculpture made out of clay
you would never explained to me the
properties of the sculpture by telling
me all about the properties of the clay
there might be certain reasons why you
could only make you know the clay would
certainly set certain constraints but
primarily the most interesting
properties of the sculpture are based on
the shaping process of the sculptures
not the properties of clay and in just
the same way but the material property
riyals of organisms do including its
genes to the extent that they give you
heritable variation that becomes a kind
of a living clay that gets molded by the
forces of survival by the environmental
forces of survival and reproduction and
there's something amazingly holistic
about this the holistic statement is is
that the parts permit the whole to have
its
but they do not cause its holes to have
its property and that is literally the
case with heritable variation is that
they permit the organism to acquire
properties by this process of adaptation
but they do not cause the organism to
have these properties evolutionary
biologists routinely make predictions
about the properties of organisms
without ever knowing a single thing
about their genes or the material makeup
there's something amazingly holistic
about it this is the approximate
ultimate distinction and evolutionary
biology surely one of the most
fundamental and yet not acknowledged not
really appreciated people who are
unfamiliar with now I sometimes bring
this home with a little exercise which I
find very instructive so ok knowing only
a brief treatment like this let's see
how well you can employ annotation just
example so reproduction is the name of
the game and evolutionary biology it
might seem that parents kill an
offspring would never evolve
why on earth would it kill their
offspring nevertheless there's a number
of environmental situations in which
infanticide can be favored by natural
selection so what are they I have the
students turn to their neighbor gusset
and groups of three and the hall erupts
in conversation you can do a little bit
of thinking your self what are the
environmental circumstances in which
infanticide might be adaptive and
reliably a year after you come up with
what we can call the big three
environmental factors favouring and fan
aside which are lack of resources you
don't have enough resources for you and
your baby and perhaps previous often so
surprised you're faced with a very tough
choice holiday from an evolutionary
perspective one needs to raise Aspen
which themselves will have offspring and
so if an offspring is very unlikely to
survive where we produced themselves
then as difficult as it might be
and this it becomes a context for a and
then the third is uncertain parentage
this is often a problem which afflicts
males males but in certain species such
as bird it's the problem that can
afflict females is this really my
offspring and if it's not then the
tremendous investment effort is not
going to be warranted from an
evolutionary perspective all of these
things follow like the natural select
parents maximizes the reproduction of
success over their whole lifetime and
this one always involves away in our
present and reproduction now I like to
think that this exercise is simple but
profound why these are college freshmen
they have minimal knowledge of
evolutionary theory hopefully they have
no direct knowledge of and fanta side
they have no knowledge of proximate
genetic or psychological mechanisms that
might underlie infanticide and despite
this they were able to correctly deduce
the major hypotheses that are in fact
employed in the study of infanticide and
that is the power of adaptation estate
got my students going basically thinking
as an adaptation esteem the very start
and as for infanticide so well so for an
infinite number of other questions this
is why Darwin could be an extreme
integrationist we could ask why Oh males
much bigger than females and some
species is in the elephant seals males
are about to e times bigger than than
females are much smaller than others
this is a deep-sea anglerfish and Slow
projection here is the living fishing
lure that ad angles are there fish come
and then got snapped up by this fish
this little projection here is the male
much smaller than the female it searches
the female out bites around the butt and
their lips fear its lips fuse with their
skin and it becomes a living bag of
sperm and so um so in this case the
sexual dimorphism goes much the other
way why do some animals blend into their
background is in this alligator snapping
turtle
their standout is in this amazing
mandrill how can we explain aging aging
certainly seems dysfunctional this is a
wonderful picture of an ornithologist as
a young man and he's banding seagulls
here and this is one of the heroic
biologists who spends his entire life
working on a single study population so
here he is about 50 years later and
that's the same bird that's the bird got
there she looks a lot better than he
does so why is it why is it that some
species senesce with a year or two and
others will can go for centuries how can
we explain this amazing variation which
exists all things that you might want to
measure such this simple algorithm of
adaptation ISM is enabling us not to put
the direct ants right answer all the
time but is giving us a really good
guess again and again and again for an
infinitude of subjects and if we can do
this for the whole natural world what
about us
what on earth would exempt humans suits
so that we could not use the same
powerful explanatory tool in order to
study our own species along with the
rest of life now let me give you a
similar exercise for adaptations be
careful what you wish for and then I'm
gonna fast-forward a little bit here but
this is another fun exercise I asked the
students to list all of the traits that
they associate with morality who would
you regard as a morally perfect
individual and I get the list that you
might expect altruism sacrifice courage
bravery and so on one year one yell one
person yelled out Jesus who is indeed
the exemplar of the morally perfect
individual and then list of all the
traits that you associate with
immorality and I got what you might
expect selfishness murder adultery all
of those things and that same year
somebody that bastard the character in
the Austin Powers movies and ever since
then I've had this disturbing image of
that bastard and Jesus together and I
can't really seem to get rid of it
and so now that we have this kind of
image of morality and immorality let's
conduct three thought experiments the
first one is what would happen if you
placed one moral individual and one
immoral individual together on a desert
island what would happen and the
students have no trouble with this the
answer is a no-brainer Memorial
individual will become shark food within
days and so this points out the
disadvantage of morality and social
interactions the morality seems to have
this intrinsic dissident in social
interactions its experiment to what
would happen if you placed a group of
moral people on one desert island and a
group of immoral people on another
desert island and this answer is also no
brainer the moral group will thrive
while the immoral group will
self-destruct so in just the same way
that there seems to be a weakness
associated with morality with respect to
social interactions with within social
interactions it's just as fundamental
that that at the group level at the
societal level morality is advantageous
compared to immorality then experiment
three now what happens if we let one
immoral individual paddle over to moral
island and one in moral individual
paddle over to immoral Island that's a
tough question because it's a messy
combination of the clear-cut answers to
the first two questions and in a
nutshell this is multilevel selection
theory which I'll be talking about on
the next two lectures first for the
biological world and then the human
world and once again simple that
profound I think the most profound
insights are often the simplest and here
what we've shown is there is nothing
unbelievable and so often evolution is
portrayed as a theory which explains
immorality and selfishness well and
altruism poorly so that we have to
explain altruism and morality elsewhere
somehow outside of evolutionary theory
but the real situation is is that
evolution has the resources to explain
both the traits that we associated with
immorality and the traits that we
associate with morality and then moral
groups survive and we produce
wonderfully even in purely biological
terms and of course if you know anything
about religion you know that often the
injunction is to be fruitful and
multiply
so there's nothing unbiased religions or
other moral systems the problem with
morality is not its biological
adaptiveness at the group level but its
vulnerability to subversion from within
so often and of course it's more
complicated than this what we call
immoral is predatory on what we call
moral and so what this means is that
approach a desirable trait pro-sociality
can either be adaptive or maladaptive
depending on the parameters of the
social environment and if we know this
well enough that perhaps we can use this
knowledge to improve the conditions for
the expression of pro-sociality this is
the sense in which evolution becomes
what was called by the student a
positive theory something that you can
do something with if we know the world
in the past and in the present we know
you know [ __ ] happens basically there's
all kinds of bad things that happen if
your theory can't explain that it's just
not a good theory but if you know that
the the the socially desirable traits
can be evolutionarily successful and you
know the conditions under which they can
be evolutionary so successful and you
can produce those conditions then you
can actually cause these things to come
into existence and your theory has done
a very useful thing and I will try to
elaborate on that kind of use of
evolutionary theory in my last talk well
now I want to wrap this up because I
want to leave some time for
questions I've already made the that any
theory doesn't just give you the right
answer straight off what it does is it
gives you a set of intelligent
alternatives but then you need the
scientific process to select among
alternatives and that's true for
evolution just as any other theory
so you think might think it doesn't need
comment yet there is endless debate
about the difficulty of testing
evolutionary and especially adaptation
astir sees this often parades under the
phrase just so strongly that when you
give an adaptation of hypothesis and
said just so strongly and this occurs
among evolutionists just as much as in
other disciplines I think it's an
amazing phenomenon because what it does
is it that it takes difficulty and it
makes difficulty replace falsehood as
the basis of rejection we're not saying
that we can't do this because it's false
we're saying it's because it's so damn
hard you can't function as a scientist
and do it and I think we really want to
pay careful attention to this and when
we look at it closely I'll bet you
anything that it is actually like
creationism it is a barrier to inquiry
and that the reason that that exists
where it does is because there's
something that we're not supposed to
touch okay and I think it's a kind of
creationism that way and if you look
carefully what you what you're going to
find and of course this is what
philosophers and historians of science
should be working on and in some cases
are is that functional hypotheses
adaptations hypotheses are no more
difficult to test than non-functional
hypotheses there's hypotheses about
adaptation ism which have been proven
endlessly and in any case they can't
substitute for each other because if you
know about the proximate ultimate
distinction what you know is that
everything that evolves requires two
explanations it requires a functional
explanation and an explanation in terms
of proximate mechanisms and the idea
that you can't test things functionally
then you switch to a none it just won't
work because there's this
complementarity of explanations
is so fundamental to evolutionary theory
I'll be saying more about non-genetic
evolutionary processes and future
lectures and so I want to they're
important of course just to say briefly
that one of the principal objections to
evolution often goes by the terms such
as genetic determinism for example and
the idea is is that because evolution is
genetic evolution and there's assumed to
be of some kind of strong relationship
between genes and behavior then this
somehow limits human potential basically
we're stuck with our genes there's
nothing we can do and so it becomes a
limitation on on human potential and I
think that a more careful understanding
of evolutionary theory in a number of
ways certainly makes this a false
conclusion and and cultures so very
important all kinds there's all kinds of
open-ended psychological processes but
we these do not stand as alternatives
evolutionary theory these must be
understood from an evolutionary
perspective and so this leads to a
concept of evolutionary social
constructivism that's an phrase that's
so newly minted that it's it's it's it's
not even published yet so revolutionary
social constructivism is another form of
integration which is almost entirely in
the future okay well I've talked about
integration at this practice by
scientist as it can be taught in the
classroom and I'd like to end with the
idea of implementing this kind of
integration at a campus-wide scale
that's what we're trying to do at
Binghamton University with our
evolutionary Studies program the website
if you visit it begins a evolution is
increasingly being used to explain the
pageant of human life in addition to the
rest of life on Earth a major it's a
program which can be taken by any
student in the university and it's a
parallel curriculum which results in a
certificate along with one's degree
there's over 50 faculty associated with
it and 15 departments in
it has a teaching function and it also
is used to integrate to incubate a
collaborative faculty and graduate
research and will soon involve
community-based research to solve
practical in addition to basic
scientific problems and I think the best
way to represent it is with the summit
our series that we have every semester
here's this spring's seminar series and
just imagine now that you were part of
this program
and you were returning all of these we
begin with the Yale zone Linda Bardo
shucks wonderful wonderful work on
genetic variation and taste perception
supertasters I hope that you're familiar
with her work
and then an archaeologist named John
Hart who thinks about archaeology from
an evolutionary perspective a computer
person who does agent-based modeling
from an evolutionary perspective very
famous social psychologist named Tim
Wilson and University of Virginia social
psychology and the subconscious mind an
ecosystem ecologist wonderful work tom
widom Northern Arizona University very
famous philosopher at the University of
Michigan and Alan Gilbert microbial
biologist at SUNY Stony Brook studies
Lyme disease from a very reductionist ik
perspective and also an evolutionary
prospective and then my co-editor
Jonathan gotcha a young literary scholar
who was brave enough to to write his
thesis in a book on on the Iliad from an
evolutionary perspective and then this
edited book in this list which which
something like it appears every single
semester is notable for two reasons the
first is is the degree to which
scientists and scholars across
disciplines are incorporating evolution
into their work and that list included
some of the most established senior
scientists today and some of the young
up-and-coming the next generation of
scientists they've become sufficiently
interested in evolution very seriously
incorporated in their own work and so
it's integration with evolutions already
taking place at the level of research
and the second notable point
is the degree to which such a diversity
of subjects can be understood and
enjoyed by a single intellectual
community the audience for these talks
will be the same people they'll be from
all subject areas and they'll be from
undergraduate students to faculty a
single intellectual community who able
to enjoy all of these lectures because
they speak the common language of
evolution and so that's why I call this
talk of sociological breakthrough what I
want to say is that the dream of
integration which has been reflected in
the Terry lectures and it's really the
mission of the Terry lectures it's close
to being realized that evolutionary
theory provides the basis for
integration perhaps not the only basis
but certainly a great one that the
extreme integration exemplified by
Darwin is already being practiced at the
level of individuals and small groups
and so what really needs to happen and
which can't happen the break period was
to establish what already exists at this
small scale at a larger scale both
inside and outside the ivory tower so
thank you very much
we're going to you know question a
discussion section says man I start off
by simply asking you you have 30 well
accounted for Darwin's own early
interest in group selection and some of
the never be falsifiable statements that
you made inflation to this we do account
for the reluctance of scientists after
the sixties to really well I know we're
still personally disgusted that until my
second lecture in which I'm going to
talk about in detail but I can give a
thumbnail sketch I think Darwin thought
they're not infallible he did say things
would prove to be incorrect he does
sound amazing we modern when you read it
and in this case he correctly perceived
this dilemma what I call the fundamental
problem a social life that a lower
natural selection at the individual
level produces many wonderful things the
insect that looks exactly like the leaf
the fish that hydrodynamically so
efficient has made difficulty explaining
the traits associated with goodness and
morality these seem to be downright
disadvantageous and so this he perceived
this and he worried about it and then he
proposed group selection as he as the
solution very clearly what happened
after that and the history of evolution
is so very interesting because many
ideas which antedated Darwin sort of
change themselves superficially and
continue forward and
superficially Darwinian turns and so his
followers became much less clear and the
whole concept of something being good
for the individual that for the group
good for the species but in the
ecosystem was lumped together there was
a period of what's called naive group
selection very sloppy thinking about
group isn't basically and this was
parallel in human sciences by tradition
called functionalism in which people
very critically thought that society was
like an organism and and more or less
everything that you saw was good for the
good for the society and it wasn't until
the 1960s that that this came brought
into question and the reaction was very
extreme and I call the last 50 years in
evolutionary biology the age of
individualism in evolutionary biology
now we're establishing a middle ground
I'll go count that in more detail
basically the subject recording partly
yes they are if you will come down to
the microphone or over to the microphone
if you can you might be better
I think you show us quite convincingly
how you could work in this seminal
setting who teach them information
education thinking well they were
wondering whether you had been equally
successful to explain the most dr.
aspects of evolutionary theory right I
mean you to take the birds actually most
of them the distinguishing features of
the parents had evolved not in order to
live as a bird there's nothing to do
primarily with flying so I mean that
that seems to be at least to me what did
people to teach to that I I don't think
it's necessarily difficult to convey and
it's fascinating in its own right I do
not give a priority in terms of the
sequence idea I think I try to think
very carefully I think I think of it in
terms of really building a conceptual
structure in the mind of the of the
student and so it's very important what
comes furnished and what comes second
and so on and that's why one reason
where I place a temptation first is
because I think it had the largest
payoff these kinds of historical
questions and especially the concept of
exaptation zazz as you would put it
where things come from they do get
entertained but they are given a lower
sort of a status in me to be the only
education what's intended to do is to
get the student bring the student into
the subject then they will take and do
take because they're very motivated to
go on a proper course mechanisms of
evolution which really teaches evolution
in a more rigorous way of course in
macro evolution and so it's a question
of an entry point basically in which I
think the priority is governed a little
bit by but give an entry point not to
slight the importance of those things
thank you for a clear presentation also
a creative way of using teaching
evaluations
I was curious you know Sumner of Yale of
course was one of the first to call
attention to issues of society and
Hofstadter his work pointed out that
early 90s or late 19th century sociology
with uh slowly evolution with notions of
social progress and notions such as the
Aryan race also a word judgmental in
regards to the value group selection so
I'm curious as how to deal with the
issue of decided when it is good and
what is functional and what is not given
the long and tortured history of
attempts to revive Darwin to society
yes your your is this working yes sir oh
you're absolutely right and I was I gave
a very abbreviated counter the very
first thing that I do and in the class
is to try to clear away some of the
underbrush basically and to talk about
the misuses of evolutionary theory in
the and there's two important points to
make one is is to acknowledge that these
misuses have taken place and the other
is to stress that they're not intrinsic
to the to the theory and so it's not as
if everyone was nice before darwin's
theory and then became mean on the basis
of the theory before darwin our own
forefathers use the principle of divine
right to this place and just possess the
indian so so we have to be clear about
the these uses and also as intellectuals
I think we have to be able to see
through them and dissociate the the the
theory from its past uses now there's a
deeper problem which is that I think
many of you probably perceived because
it's easy enough that that this theory
of group selection multi-level selection
although it explains the traits that we
associate with goodness it also tends to
limit them to within group interactions
and between group interactions or
something else entirely and so it's not
as if group selection theory just
produces niceness in many ways you go
out of the out of the frying pan of
within group interactions into the fire
of between group interactions and so
it's implicit in the theory that the
dynamics of between group interactions
are going to be different and more
challenging even more challenging than
the dynamics of within group
interactions now that's a good thing in
the sense that the theory has two jobs
to do one is to explain the world as it
existed in the past and the present and
the other is to hopefully improve the
world in the future and we know that
this problem of between group
interactions are
this I mean any any realistic person
knows that this is Truman this is bad
for religious groups as it is for other
kinds of groups actually it's not worse
I don't think but it's bad and so
clearly if your theory can't explain
this double standard of us versus them
then it's not a good theory in that
sense it's good that we can explain it
we'd also like to solve it basically so
the theory of we understand this is
their way that we constructor between
group interactions in order to foster
cooperation and that's the second
interesting interesting question so I
hope that I've adequately answered your
answered your question
my question is
yeah it's a really good question and I'm
glad to have the opportunity to address
it because obviously it's something that
one needs to think about I'm very
sympathetic to the problem of a theory
that explains everything
explaining nothing so and so this is
actually you know it's there's two
interesting kinds of answers let's say
that you were to pose this question for
non-human species you know what is it
about Drosophila that we cannot explain
by evolution okay and in some ways the
answer is nothing evolution can explain
everything about Joseph Lawai because
there's some sense in which evolution
strives to be a complete accounting
system and so gene frequency change for
example it includes drift it includes a
selection there could be all kinds of
stuff so we're not saying that
everything is adaptive but what you want
to do is you want to get all the inputs
and all the outputs all the vectors
basically and already so that you know
what's going to happen to the system so
in a broad sense you're trying to have a
complete counting system in that sense
it's good to explain everything and a
more narrow sense than that accounting
system has to have various categories so
that you're not being so empty as to
explain everything can be explained by
selection for example because it might
be drift or it might be hitchhiking or
something like that so as long as you
have meaningful categories within your
system then you're not being empty
because you're being able to place
things in these various categories and I
think that when we think of our humans
we become much more complex and the
inclusion of all kinds of processes
which we think of this cultural and
psychological we have intentional
thought we have all kinds of
sophisticated psychology which is
beneath conscious awareness and then we
also have processes of blind variation
selection social experiments
which fail all kinds of nonlinear
processes which which are not Linode
basically so they really fall under the
category of complexity without without
resulting in adaptations and so in some
sense we want a theory which
incorporates all of these just so that
we could have a complete accounting
system and another sense we need to have
lots of meaningful categories within
that system so that we don't suffer from
the emptiness of saying that our theory
explains everything and religion is a
good example which I'm going to describe
in more detail the nice thing about
evolution is that it offers several
theories of religion this religions
individually advantageous good for the
group cultural parasite it can be
maladaptive for some reason it could be
because it's because it's it's suited to
ancient environments it can be a
byproduct so that's a sense in which you
want to have a complete field of
theories but you also need to have these
sub categories and I think I'll probably
leave it at that but hopefully you know
you'll be pleased with basically the way
I try to deal with that in the case of
in the case of human groups
I hope so I don't know myself that the
evolution of the evolution of technology
is a great great topic and and so and
and you know quite a few people do study
that kind of thing another is the
effects of computers on communication
and so what that does in terms of in
terms of social organization the kinds
of groups that can exist connected by
computers which could never have existed
before
so in some sense computers have changed
thee and this has been true throughout
history loads and other forms of
navigation and things like that have
been have been very influential and in
an altering the population structure
which is important in evolutionary terms
your assertions those coming in with
religious belief in completely
unchanging their viewpoints or even
unscathed it sounds from what you're
saying so I can only imagine in my own
mind one of two options that the type of
student that you have there's either so
far on that let's just say a little
political or religious spectrum that
they were able to absorb this and
without any type of what I or do you do
some type of work in your classroom
setting to make sure that someone who
would come in with more of a
or more of a belief a stronger more
rigid belief system you me from the
get-go say hey you could have your deity
and your evolution to how much time you
spend trying to build that framework or
is my first one to correct it maybe your
students are a type that I shouldn't be
taking no I don't I don't think my
students are unusual and at the same
time I don't I don't go to special work
to prepare them or counsel Homer or
anything like that so I think that the
answer is more interesting than that and
the answer now with someone who's been
studying religion hard and interacting a
lot with religious believers and and
religious folks who are very interested
in the science religion interface I
taught a remarkable course called
evolution religion in which the students
came in again the full spectrum and in
the semester they we studied a survey
which I'll talk about on the third in my
third lecture so we were studying
evolution religion hard and in that
class and the reason that is possible
for a religious person to come through
we go through as you say without a
hiccup is that I think religious faith
and and belief obviously you need to
divide it up into a number of components
part of that is the actual belief in
supernatural agents and as something is
more than a social construction and that
of course is going to be challenged by
an evolutionary account because like any
naturalistic account then we're trying
to explain religion and some secular
fashion as a social as a social
construction and yet other parts of
religious belief have to do with with of
course pro-sociality peace on earth
being part of something larger than
ourselves communicating our values to
our children and what fascinates me
about religious discourse whenever I
listen to it is that it's about 95
percent other stuff in other words stuff
which can be explained
and frankly pragmatic terms and so if
you deliver a theory which is explaining
how we might get these things in a
practical way a person who values them
is going to love it so there's a there's
a there's a an affinity basically which
is and I think often and this depends on
the particular kind of beliefs that a
religious believer has I think that in
many cases there's an implicit knowledge
awareness that the actual theistic
beliefs are in some sense instrumental
okay and in the person and that they're
choosing the legend they're choosing
this belief versus that belief in order
that they have a good environment for
their children or that they can do this
oh they can and they can do that and if
that the actual practical benefits that
they're looking for is enough in the
forefront that that overshadows
basically the the the the more
conflictual aspects of taking this on
these are dominant and it seems like
this kind of thinking can easily yeah
another great question and I feel like
getting a number of answers at the at
the highest level of intellectual
discourse this is the kind of question
which should be and is being asked by
people such as Alan gibart a very well
respected moral philosopher okay
and so one point to make is that when
we're talking about integration the
reason that philosophers are very much
in the mix as far as evolutionary
studies is concerned is because so many
of these fundamental questions about
ethics and and epistemology and and and
so on really does require I think just
cannot avoid the consideration of the
fact that we are of evolution and so the
kind of question that you ask would be
the kind of question which which will be
debated basically at the at the at the
top okay
the typical answer that someone would
give to that would say no that would be
the naturalistic fallacy
and you can't derive optimum is and and
I've done quite a lot of thinking on
this and that kind of usage is actually
quite a bit simplistic it's kind of like
the use of a cross to ward off vampires
I I think and and and so the problem is
more complex than that but surely if
anything comes through its that it
nobody really would or should confuse
what is adaptive what evolves with what
is good and I think that if you look at
the whole concept of a moral of
immorality just in the common sense
everyday use of the term it's implicit
that immoral behaviors benefit the
immoral individual for heaven's sakes we
need an evolution to tell us that
obviously no one would tempted to
perform immoral acts if they did not
benefit at the expense of others and so
if you're going to define morality
just in the common sense of the term
then it's got to the other oriented the
morality is something which is good for
the group or good for the others are
something I mean that is so axiomatic
about morality that that wants you
define that and in an evolutionary
context you're saying is that you know
in moral traits which we call amoral at
times they're evolutionarily
advantageous and that's why we see them
and again I mean evolution better make
that prediction because otherwise you
would predict it and well traits don't
exist and that's not the case so quickly
you get to this kind of common-sense
middle-ground
in which the idea of its natural
therefore it's good is not really I mean
it wouldn't be it wouldn't be part of of
the next at the same time there are
that's not to say that the difficulties
don't arise and in a paper which I'm
happy to happy to give you we talk about
things like rape as an example which has
been discussed where the rape is an
adaptive strategy and in males and if
you look at the legal history you know
the status of rape and and and and so on
you find out very much there's a concept
of the natural man basically you know
what is a person our conception of human
nature figures in what we regard us as
right and wrong so that there is a
connection between the facts of the
world and morality the naturalistic
fallacy does not completely cut that
connection so I think the point is is
that this gets complex in a very
interesting way and it's something to
dive into it's not something to -
they're shy away from and it is not not
any sense in which it leads to an
outcome which you wouldn't actually be
perfectly inclined to embrace just
talking about in a non evolutionary
terms I think this is a very interesting
sense in which in which a person such as
yourself would get very interested in
evolution but would not change your
basic values if you were to learn more
about evolution you'd find that you
could act
make your point more effectively
basically by talking in evolutionary
terms but you wouldn't you wouldn't
change your basic perspective answered
my questions a name and a face to moral
and immoral gluts so you want me to name
a moral group or an immoral group well I
don't expect to be stumped but I think
let me just uh that's um an interesting
question
well no I think I can do a little bit
better than this if you look in this
really wonderful work I presumably I
will get a chance to talk about it
certainly in private conversation and
with basically the cheater problem that
I presented very briefly and a few luck
of wonderful literature and the
experimental economics literature which
basically their cooperation games and if
you were to get a bunch of people around
they all can contribute to a common pot
or not it gets doubled and to be
distributed to everybody basically you
set up a prisoner's dilemma situation
which is possible of cheat and in this
situation you get a mix of responses and
individual differences come across very
strongly and on most of these social
situations big literature multiple
literature's on this which basically say
that that human life along with other
species is like an interest Pacific
creditor prey interaction
they're the co-operators and they
benefit from their collective activities
and then they're the ones that break in
and they take and and you would expect
this okay so it's not hard to locate a
slacker or a cheater
these folks exist and probably exist in
all of us because life is so heavily so
not only other individual differences
but there's huge behavioral flexibility
so that any one of us would probably be
a cheater in certain situations and not
others to you you must acknowledge very
important individual differences and you
almost must also must acknowledge very
important individual flexibility then
that whole problem replicates itself
that you go to the group level you might
have individuals or very solid citizens
that doing great things for their group
but that group is now working to exploit
other groups and this simply reputable
represents itself again and again and
again and so I think it's actually quite
feasible and implicit in the whole
subject that one thing about actually
most populations this is an interesting
discovery and we you call it us used to
think of species as kind of uniform
they fill a single niche for example but
more and more we're discovering that
single species and single populations
are very diverse individual differences
which can be explained in the same way
as as a species differences basically
and so when it comes to cooperation we
always have this kind of eternal
struggle that we're going to that we're
going to see between cooperation and
defection various of its guises and
we're going to see mechanisms which sort
of wait things in the in the form of
cooperation then we go up and get these
groups as corporate units all of those
clubs are going to exist again and
that's how that's what it's like and I
think that when we assign morality and
immorality of it we can because we use
those words a lot and of course a lot of
it depends on our perspective so very
clearly if you are a member of a group
which is exploiting another group you're
very likely to regard yourself as a
highly moral individual and so also
everyone else be in your in your group
that's the that's the problem of course
and you see this playing itself out all
the time
god Bless America is a great it would be
a great example or god bless any any
group so I really think that there is a
theory here which helps us to explain
this sort of panoramic view of within
and between group interactions and then
how we overlay that on the conventional
and and intellectual notions of morality
and immorality is basically our
challenge as intellectuals to to to do
that but the theoretical framework is
there and I think that if you just with
the experience that we have both our
everyday experience and our experiences
as more systemic academics is just an
amazing field of opportunity I'll try to
convey that in my third lecture on on
human groups as adaptive units and if we
can use this framework to explain the
nature of religion basically
reception 124 prospects read again